[Music]
Moron piece tells the stories of a
number of the diplomats who have been
deeply engaged in North Korea diplomacy
over the last several administrations
and I think it's a historical when you
hear people say those were all failures
we didn't get anything done under the
Clinton administration we had a really
substantive framework agreement with the
North Koreans where they made a lot of
commitments that would have been very
important in the long term to slowing
their progress as a nuclear power and
the United States actually reneged on a
lot of the commitments that we made on
our end you know we were in no small
part responsible for the collapse of
that deal then subsequently during the
George W Bush administration you know
you had a situation where Bush after the
disasters of Iraq set about doubling
down on diplomacy and they led six-party
talks a career diplomat named Chris Hill
went over there and spent countless
hours talking to all of the players and
they actually shut down some of the
reactors for the first time in years you
know they were starting to give us some
information about their nuclear
development in the end they did cheat it
did fall through and that wasn't our
fault
but we did make some inroads
particularly in our conversation with
China about North Korea which is going
to be a pivotal part of any solution
going forward now you see the Trump
administration coming in with this kind
of madcap approach you know diplomacy by
tweet all this saber-rattling now
potentially a meeting between leaders
and the reality is we don't know how
that's gonna pan out could it work sure
and I and I think everyone else invested
in this problem sincerely hope that it
does but what those experts whose
stories are in more on piece say one
after another is we are flying blind now
and we don't have to be you could have
the same kind of saber rattling and
tough approach you could have the same
kind of leader to leader meeting and
also insulate yourself against some of
these pitfalls make sure that we are not
accidentally legitimizing the North
Koreans as a nuclear power make sure
that we are hip
the fact that they very often lie about
the kinds of commitments they're making
now and have done sort so in the past
there is a real risk here that we get
played
look North Korea will continue to be
perilous it was perilous under the
previous regime it is perilous now I
think that the thaw in relations between
the north and the south is one of the
most positive developments to come along
and that's due to a number of factors
not just what's happening in the United
States right now but ultimately
regardless of who is in the seat of
power there we are going to need a core
of experts who are experienced in the
ways in which these regimes one after
another are difficult and lie to the
rest of the world and pose a threat to
that region and I have complete
confidence in one thing which is whoever
comes along next in terms of North
Korean leadership we're going to need
some people who are really well versed
in dealing with that region if we want
to keep them contained you know I think
that the fondest desire of this regime
in North Korea is to gain international
acceptance as a nuclear power and it's
very unclear that a meeting of any kind
is going to halt that they have
certainly lied about their willingness
to halt that before the risk but this
meeting is that we play into their hands
and say yeah sure we acknowledge you as
an equal on the international stage and
we give up some of our leverage and
having them want that contact without
that leader-to-leader access which could
make the nitty-gritty work of actually
implementing diplomacy and making sure
that they are contained as a nuclear
power that much more difficult
[Music]